thank you
uh yeah so hey I'm Aiden
um
so
I'm just going to preface this talk by
saying I haven't been actively working
on these gems in over a year so there
are probably questions I won't be able
to answer and if anything's confusing
it's because I'm glossing over details I
don't know but please feel free to ask
any questions stop me at any time
um yeah
so we're going to cover the yeah
um so talk about a bit of background uh
the magically the magically gem how that
was created uh the Mustachio gem which
is built on magically
um and then
time and interest permitting we'll talk
about like some performance uh
considerations that we encountered when
when using this Gem and maybe we'll have
time to build effect I don't know
so
for those
who aren't familiar juxt is a site is a
blogging site so it's very visual
so this is my personal
uh Jack's homepage jux is a company I
used to work at a couple years ago so
it's this very
um visual presentation of videos and and
articles Etc
lots of really
um
you know full screen templates different
different sorts of layouts Etc
so
we ran into the problem that we were
needing images in a lot of different
scenarios and a lot of different aspect
ratios different sizes Etc
um it's a wysiwyg
editor so
for example this one photo is displayed
one two three
four times on this just on this one page
as well as
what we give to Facebook for uh open
graph tags what we um
you know embed in the HTML for for
Google to pick up Etc so
there was a need to
give images efficiently and not only to
take the original image but to be able
to actually modify it so
you can on the Fly
which I'm not finding for some reason
so you can apply on the on the Fly
effects
okay don't know why it's not working but
there's things like you know Lomo
effects tilt shift grayscale Etc
so
the question came up how are we going to
deal with
having all these different images they
have to be
gender down the fly we don't know what
effects people are going to apply to
them we have to support a lot of
different sizes those sizes can change
as you saw
in the home page
this layout you know all these articles
are and posts are displayed in different
sort of formats when I refresh the page
it's actually a random layout so it will
actually change uh for each user visits
every time I visit
so this means there's a lot a lot of
variations to the possible images that
we can generate so how a lot of sites
tackle image uploads is for user
generated images
is that you
have an image uploader you
store it on S3 or whatever file storage
you want and then you generate a handful
of different sizes that you might need
for
different places being presented like
the thumbnail and the small version
medium large Etc
so let's say we started with this this
photo
so you not only need to keep the
original around because you want you
want to have the High Fidelity version
for when you generate the others you'll
need a large version for when you
present the full screen you'll need a
small version 20 in the gallery you'll
need a a thumb version for when you you
put it in the thumbnail picker Etc
so
that's fine
you just generate them all up front and
add you know some sort of extension that
sort of
keeps track of okay what what sizes what
sizes uh have I generated for this and
so it's all done up front and this is
how a lot of sites do it it works fine
for if you have a relatively small
number of ways these images are being
presented
because we had a nearly infinite number
of variations and our Gallery uh the way
it was displaying images we would add
new variations all the time so it could
it could even change
you know the options the options could
change uh continually
so
as an experiment
um
I was thinking and I apologize it's cut
off but instead of an image tag where
you
just embed some static photo what if as
the image is embedded when you're asked
when you the browser is asking to use
the image you tell it
you tell the server what size you want
back and that's what it gives you so
instead of just calling for the image
directly
we're going to call through this API
that I called Magic and magically
supports not only this not only the
source image which you pass but you can
pass different parameters uh
the most common of which being resized
you can say Okay I want this photo and
fit it in a 200 by 200 box
you could also say Okay I want it to
beat 200 pixels wide and however tall
it scales too so there's a lot of a lot
of different variations that we wanted
to support you know I want to Res I want
to
cropped to 200 by 200 square and make a
grayscale for certain for certain
presentations
so this is really awesome because
instead of just having a static a static
photo where you have the side up front
what you're going to support
instead
it happens on the fly it happens at time
the image generation happens at the time
that you need them
so the way the architecture works is
instead of
just talking to static files you instead
talk through
well that's better thank you
so you instead talk through a cache and
you talk through this app called
magically so what magically does is
takes those parameters it fetches the
source image that we passed in and then
applies whatever Transformations we want
so resize in a simple case it could also
be grayscale or what have you
so
the other awesome part about this is if
we decide to change what's being
presented in the gallery we don't all of
a sudden have all these lingering uh you
know 200 by 500 pixel images that we're
not going to use anymore
so there's no state in the sense that
you request an image that's what gets
served back you never have to worry
about cleanup on the server
so this is really nice you can
just let a cash handle
the storing of the images you say uh you
know we used a least recently used cache
and so that says okay if this uh you
know store X number of of gigs of files
and whatever whichever one has not been
requested recently
throw away throw away those first
so
for return visits it ends up being a
fast request because you already have
that image generated and you can put a
CDN in front of you know this is a a
cache we had a in servers you know on
our own machines but we put a CDN in
front of it as well so you get caching
them all for layers and
we just made the decision that okay once
you've requested this image it's going
to be good forever so you can set that
expiration
to be forever you never have to worry
about it regenering those images if
you're cash can hold off
so magically is this this app I wrote
this gem
which can be hosted by itself uh and
I'll show you that in a second or it can
it's actually just a small Sinatra app
because Sinatra is built on a rack
any rack app can be embedded before
another you can actually take a rails
app and embed it within another rails
app you can take magically and embed it
within a rails app
so magically sits on top of a library
called dragonfly dragonfly
um is actually a sort of a full-fledged
like attachments
management uh gem so something like
carrier wave or paper clip it handles
similar cases to that I'm actually just
using it because it has a nice interface
to image magic so image magic
is think command line Photoshop it
allows you to do Transformations on
images all through
uh arguments in the command line
and that's why I try and mirror and
magically
so if we just take a quick peek the
documentation
so there's a bunch of different there's
all setup information
but there's a lot of uh parameters that
correspond very closely to what the
image magic current image magic of
arguments would be so for example to
adjust that one's broken don't mind that
one
but if you pass flip true the command
line argument actually looks the same in
in image magic and we'll see that in a
second
but you know you can not only have these
sort of Boolean operations you can also
do things like uh you know I have
multiple parameters so glow takes the
amount of glow and the softness of the
glow whatever that means
um but these are essentially just being
passed through to image magic so you can
think of magically as an API for image
transformation a web API for image magic
so enough slides
so like I said magically is a Sinatra
app so
within uh the folder you'll find this
magically app class so it has some
configuration
uh it has some some setup Etc
but it otherwise just has routes like
you do for a plain old Sinatra app
because for various reasons I'll maybe
go into them later we support a bunch of
different it supports a bunch of
different syntaxes
um
so you can either use Query parameters
or you can do
slash Q slash and then each sort of key
key value pair of arguments so you say
you know Q slash glow slash 100 comma 20
slash you know resize slash 200 Etc
so there's a bunch of these different
there's a handful of these different
syntaxes so all these routes uh
determine if you're asking for
um
for an operation to be done if you're if
you're trying to look at the home page
so if it sees a source URL
it does the transformation otherwise
no wrong one sorry
um
down here so if if it sees a source URL
it processes the image otherwise it
displays the homepage
so this process source is where the
actual action is happening
so back in the magically class
um
so we take
we take the source URL and we fetch the
image from wherever it's coming from so
this you know can can be hosted on S3 it
can be from an external site Etc
magically itself doesn't have any
limitation on um on what that can be
so once that image is fetched uh you do
the processing and the options are being
passed through a hash the options being
different Transformations that you want
to happen and they're ordered uh luckily
in Ruby 193
um or I'm sorry 192 and up hashes are
actually ordered so
so the the the order in which you apply
the parameters matters
so
for each operation if you're able to
find the processor method that is if we
support that transformation
um
you know if it's if it's a Boolean
operation we just do it otherwise we
pass whatever value through
so
I won't show all the processor methods
get get wired up because that's not
really interesting but one thing I
really wanted to do with magically was
make it easily configurable and easily
extensible so there's sort of built-in
commands that come with image magic
things like resizing and grayscale Etc
but I also wanted to have kind of
compound effects so where you could say
you know grayscale doesn't mean one one
particular thing it has certain you know
thresholds that you set the white
balance so that you set the black level
or contrast whatever
um
so I want to be able to specify these
these sort of custom effects and like
Lomo you know actually comprises a lot
of different effects together
so I support uh what dragonfly calls
shortcuts
so in here you can actually see in the
back you said all right
okay
so in here you actually have the
definitions for every single
transformation that's supported
so
brightness and contrast I do some
checking to make sure that uh they're
actually passing through valid values
that's
um
a number followed by a plus blah blah
blah
so
once it determines that
um
you know these are nasty regex's just to
make sure that um
you know the different syntaxes uh are
proper
but if it gets passed in properly we
call the convert command so convert is
the image magic command for during an
operation so you say convert and then
some uh and then the input file and then
some arguments and then the output
effect
so here the process convert is saying
okay take the input file which is what
we
um specified source
apply
these uh this argument to it so the
brightness contrast flag with some value
uh and then the output
because you can
pass multiple
um
parameters in at one time and I'll show
a demonstration of that so we have the
glow with 1.2 and 20. I can also do
flip equals true
and I'm able to chain effects really
really easily
so this you know in a traditional app
this would have required me writing code
would have required to deploy uh would
have required maybe some generating of
you know existing images here is as
simple as adding a command line art all
right yeah query parameter
so
you know the sort of built-in ones like
brightness contrast saturation they call
modulate but these are all you know the
sort of built-in commands with image
magic I also have more
uh
complicated ones like tilt shift and
this I was really
I mean I don't know anything about about
image transformation or the terms or
anything like that so it was really just
me looking at tutorials about how to do
certain effects in Photoshop or in
illustrator mapping the I'm sorry in uh
an image magic translating those to the
actual
you know what set of commands tweaking
tweaking uh the parameters or the the
multiples or whatever uh to to get
something that I liked
and then I can add it as a as a shortcut
so you can pass in tilt shift with some
coefficients and that gets passed to the
polynomial function which is the way the
um you know the sort of the density in
which the blur is applied
so these were really fun to do I highly
encourage uh you know if you find
Photoshop difficult and frustrating you
should try doing it on a command line
but uh it is really really satisfying to
to see things you know come out the way
you want and
um
trying to think of
some example there are some that I
actually
um
here I actually was like looking at the
Curves in Photoshop you know I had taken
original photo I'd create some some
uh layer effect I think they call it uh
or mask in Photoshop and I'd actually
like look at the curve or uh you know
get it to tell me the the polynomial of
the curve and translate that to code
so this is all within like I said
magically is both a gem and an app
itself so you can actually just clone
the repo and throw it up on GitHub or
I'm sorry if they're up on Heroku
um
you can also take the gem add it to your
existing app and mount it within you
know certain route
so that's
magically any questions about that thus
far anything you want to see in more
detail or anything like that
sure so
um
so the cache is nothing special meaning
it's nothing that we built in-house
um
what we what we did is because you
all these
you know where
um if you have file servers you have to
you know you're only going to have that
each version of each image stored once
probably so you have to have a system in
front of it that says okay where is
you know that image stored and make sure
to serve it from the right place Etc
um and as you get multiple servers and
like do sharding like around the world
and whatever I like it's more
complicated here
because
um so we were using uh
oh my God what's the jruby server
okay well we're using jruby at the time
and uh not Tomcat but the other one I'm
sorry
I'll think of it
um essentially it's a server that allows
you to have
um
I don't have a slide for this but it
allows you to basically make
um
this these
sort of compound apps so you're able to
say okay deploy my rails app and deploy
this Sinatra app and deploy whatever
like all on the same server and also
um you know put uh Apache
in front of you know these these
particular
ly so what our cash uh would do is
because this server actually supported
um you know sharding in the sense where
it would handle the caching uh on
whatever server you know happened to
generate the image first and then
the servers would then talk to one
another if if the one didn't have
didn't have the image it would go and
fetch it from from one that did if it
had already been generated
so the cache was nothing special it was
just uh Apache cache I think you know
whatever the the sort of
plain old plugins
and this is really nice because you can
throw up as many magical instances as
you want or as you need they're all
exactly the same you can you know scale
them up and down uh
however you want
you know if you have heavy traffic you
can just throw up more they're all
they're all identical and because
uh the the files are getting stored at
the cash level they're all
they're all stateless and they all
um you know just serve one request at a
time and they
you know that's it
there's no there's no keeping of State
there's no keeping track of have I
generated this or not you know which
other servers have it or whatever
um it's very simple
so
using cash you know this this
idea of of using a cache basically as
your data store or as your file store is
really really convenient and something I
definitely encourage you to do if you
end up building like apps with a decent
amount of traffic uh or or need
something where you have to serve serve
these sort of generated files
did any other specific questions yeah
no and that's sort of the beauty of it
like magically you know just works as a
single a single node you can just do
requests to it
um I didn't put any authentication in
there I didn't put any caching logic in
there whatever you could you know add
rack cash if you want something really
simple you can put uh you know Apache or
nginx or uh you know whatever whatever
other like
caching server you want in front of it
that's all
you know nothing nothing is built into
management magical doesn't have to know
what's in front of it just says I get
this request I need to generate a nice
bit of back and I said caching headers
yeah
so
um one big disadvantage is because
you're only generating them on fly you
your user has to wait longer to see that
image the first time
uh if it's something where they are you
know clicking an effect and what that
applied it wouldn't be any different
whether it's not getting down their
Quest side or pressing the button causes
it to generate and then it gets
displayed yeah that's effectively the
same
yeah I mean they
yeah
so uh I can show you
so jumping ahead a little bit but
looking at uh
like the Mustachio let's see
so this is the Mustachio like new rock
graph so
Mustachio is doing more than just
generating it just uh applying effect it
actually has to do phase detection we'll
talk about that later but you know
generating these the average response
time is
see uh
half a second
uh one second you know multiple seconds
and like some of our effects took a long
time like
eight seconds all right real but it's
not
um the app is doing very little you're
basically CPU bound it's it's well
you're both CPU and I O bound so you
first have to request the image
um from an external Source if it's on
your own server that'll be fast
but you know it's doing http
record then
once it gets that image just has the 10
file and then runs uh image magic you
know convert on it that's where those
two operations are like 98 of the time
you know all magically is doing is
parsing the parameters and then uh
you know showing those both out so um I
think either we talked about or we
actually did
um
do a little hack where
to get the image because we did want
that image for some images to be
generated up front we would actually
sort of seed the cache by just running a
bunch of HTTP requests again it's
magically so we would you know request
images and they'd get generated they'd
get cash
the requester would throw them on the
ground
so this is akin to you know running a
batch like
uh you know generate job like you do if
you if you're generating them up front
so yeah the downside is that if you are
only doing that request time you have to
wait for them to be generated for the
first person that sees that image
um
you know the image might not be around
forever if it gets dropped on your cache
but
that's you know if your cash is big
enough they'll never get thrown away
that's really no different than if you
had a file store that
was starting all these
um so that that sort of scales in the
same way in the sense of storage
uh so it's exactly the same so I
I request this where are we
so like I request this image and it's
actually just an image you know it gives
the proper mime type back and whatever
um
yeah it's exactly it's exactly the same
because you know if it isn't to generate
that image request will be really slow
Google might penalize you for that I
don't know
um if it's being generated for the first
time
um
yeah but
uh yeah that's something I trade-off is
is that you have to be you have to know
that
the first thing to hit that to request
request a particular set of
Transformations on an image be it your
user be it some automated thing uh it
will be a slow slow request
any other yeah
um
but isn't it 2.0 that the fact
is not that I know
um and we because we
were up until like this afternoon
supporting uh uh Ruby 187 it actually
um
I think like parses the it actually
passes an array instead of a instead of
a hash uh just as a sort of like
you know safety to make sure it's
ordered
but I if I didn't rip that out already I
will because because the order hash
any other questions
all right so
so that's magically so if you embed it
in your app you can actually uh then
their instructions in the readme to do
this but you can actually Define your
own
uh shortcuts by you know basically doing
this top bit
so if you're in rails app say you'd say
you know magically dragonfly configure
and then you can create your own
shortcut uh
a job it's also known as
so
you know we had um specific effects that
were that were sort of custom to junks
you know are sort of Secret Sauce
effects uh so you know some made it into
magically proper but others you know if
you have a watermark say you can
actually Define a custom effect for that
so as a proof of concept
I wanted to show that um
I wanted to show that magically was
extensible
so
I don't remember if this was after we
actually started using it within jocks
or not basically as a way to prove that
prove to myself that other apps can be
built around it
um I don't know where this idea came
from but I thought wouldn't it be fun if
you could
you know I was really excited about this
API for images so what if there were an
API where you can give it an image and
it will come back
with that same image with a mustache and
all the faces
sensible right
um so I created a
gem called Mustachio and a site called
nastashify.me
so mustache5.me works it's just a very
thin wrapper around around magically
um
it just takes
a single query parameter source and will
then apply
uh
this mustacheify effect
so we can
throw in any photo we want
come on
that's a big one that's gonna take a
while
so once you pass in this source
you know it just has an effect that it
defaults to which is mustache5 so it
actually does
a request out to a face detection API
binds all the faces in the photo and
um
and then takes a mustache uh
image and positions it on all the faces
are there different gems to be used for
that so the core piece of it is
small
and I'll try it
um
so the core piece of it is just
magically it's just doing the same thing
it's requesting an image and then it's
applying a transformation to be able to
do that transformation it actually has
to do another step where it's actually
talking to a face detection API uh so
this is like a third party service we'll
see if this works
um
so it's actually a third party service
that you like magically you set an API
except instead of giving back an image
uh it gives back coordinates of all the
faces in the photo
um
I so I started off with one called
face.com but they got bought by Facebook
um so now I'm using a different one but
I believe this one gives like the eyes
the nose two or three points on the
mouth or something like that
um
so I'm
well I'll show you but I'm using that
data
so
Mustachio just has
a lot in there but it depends on
magically
it
has its own app where it um
you know takes the
and I'll uh I'll bring this up in a
second but you can actually ask for
different mustaches to be applied
um yeah same kind of logic if there's an
image uh you know process the image and
show it otherwise show the home page
so uh oh there's a gallery there we go
so
slow okay so they're actually this is
something I added later but
um you can actually pick different
mustaches to be applied so I like number
four
personally
so the app is only slightly different in
that this impacts the syntax uh
you know supports this number as the
first argument
but otherwise it's doing the same thing
it's calling uh
it's calling magically processed Source
except it does a default uh
operation of mustachify either with the
stash number that you pass in like we
just did or just true so just give the
default one
or you can also ask it for a random one
um
so what it's actually doing
is if we look at
you know like I said uh you can add
your own uh if you embed magically in
another app which is the case here
um you
configure magically to have new
those are analyzers that's not the same
thing
okay
so
I'll talk about about why this a little
different but basically this is saying
Okay add a different option for
conversion this mustache five uh takes
the stash number
and this converts so
magic is actually using a uh a fork of
magically
um
by default dragonfly for one reason or
another every operation you
call
happens independently so if I call
resize and then grayscale it first does
the resize spits back an image and then
reads that image and does the grayscale
and then spits out a new image so you
actually lose time in the encoding and
decoding of these files
so this was
a problem that we ran into is that you
know these the sandwich generation was
taking a really long time and you know
this is one place we found to cut it out
so it's a little bit more complicated so
it's actually not in like magically
Master yet
um because yeah just the syntax is a
little nastier I need to figure out how
to how to make it simpler but basically
it's building up all the commands and
then it
consolidates them all into one single uh
one single operation so the encoding
only and decoding only happened once
so
and those are called factories so uh
so we have a smashify factory
so it
looks at the
it does a pre-identify so identifies the
um image magic command to get the sort
of properties of image so things like
the the width the height the uh number
of colors Etc
so it gets the size it's
converts the image uh down to 900 Max
900 pixels Max on each side
um
and then sends that
it gets the face data as pixels
so this
I believe happens here
faced at it there we go okay so it takes
in a file
um
a job is just like a different internal
representation of that
um
and then calls calls this this API to
get to get the face data back and then
it does some normalization
yep so I'm not doing any of that I'm
just talking to an API that says and I
say tell me where all the faces are and
it just gonna be points it gives me
coordinates
um so the way that's actually done is
pretty complicated like they're they're
pretty
uh it's it's actually like a third party
service it's a website
um yeah so so I'm talking to a different
API
um
you know I I've experimented with doing
it locally
um so that you don't have that whole
round trip uh
but like performance for this is not
really a huge concern for me
um so and it's just easier so uh
yeah but it basically it looks for you
know
contrast where the nose ends and the
sides of the face are it looks for
something in a general shape it looks
for the eyes in particular you know
knowing that okay these two dots that
look sort of similar you know based on
how they're tilted the nose is going to
be straight perpendicular from that you
know and so it has all these heuristics
right yeah so there's it can only and
you know if you've looked at as many uh
yeah
yeah I don't I don't have her anymore
but um
okay but yeah basically yeah it has a
hard time detecting you know
yep
yeah yeah so so you know if it's
sideways or if there's Shadow or Etc
um if the dog you know it doesn't it
doesn't it doesn't work for everything
um but it does pretty well depending on
the service
so it gets this face data back it then
passes it through
is
it then goes through each face
um
grabs the associated mustache image and
then it's
finds where the center of the mouth is
so I guess I guess this API just gives
back the the left and right points of
the mouth so it does uh you know it just
gets the uh middle
then I'm doing some geometry to
basically shrink the mustache so that
it's a little smaller
let's see where are we
so it's some proportion of the distance
between the nose and the middle of the
mouth uh you know and then rotate it
properly Etc
um
so I mean this looks gross it's just
geometry
um
yeah you know a tan square root et
cetera uh
yeah I mean it was like drawing on
napkins like you know like like a god
like hypotenuse like
um yeah I mean it was really like okay
if the nose is X then you know then the
mouth is like half of the distance
between these two points and so you know
yeah I mean that was really what it was
so it's not that it's nothing super
fancy but it's it's doing scaling and
it's doing rotation uh and positioning
so this concatenates some uh big string
of
uh
so yeah it starts with like a
transparent background because you want
the
you're essentially uh if you've used
Photoshop you you create different
layers so you have a layer for each
mustache so you want that layer to have
a transparent background
um turn on the alpha Channel you know
which which allows transparency
uh you you come up with the coordinates
and then you do a transformation which
is down here so it's saying distort uh
SRT I don't scale rotation
transformation stands for so you pass in
like a couple arguments there and that
positions position that um that mustache
so it's doing each of these in
parentheses so each mustache is being
transformed independently and they all
get flattened at the end so the layers
get compressed
any questions around that
uh so that all this is where it's
calculating so you see like face nose
and mouth Center Etc this is where it's
actually so here I'm like calculating
the height of the mustache uh the
rotation of the mustache
the mouth intersect I guess is the oh
okay
so for
where is it
okay somewhere in here I'm actually
defining
um for each mustache because they all
have to have different shapes
so because they all have different
shapes you don't want to you know I
started off at this topmost so okay I
figured the the bottom should go past
the middle of the mouth and so that was
that was easy to do the second one you
want it to drop below
so each
each mustache actually has a
specification that goes along with the
image that says okay we want the overlap
to be this amount we want the top offset
to be a certain amount so like the
uh
so like number three or no
four down there you want to be a little
lower on the face than uh number one
or you know lower relative to the nose
so you know it's all it's it's it was
all just like tweaking it's it's not not
anything super fancy it was just you
know
seeing mustache applied and you know it
didn't look right and so so
just playing around with with how to get
it to look
uh look right it'd look good
so
yeah match I didn't bring it up before
but uh magical also supports analyzers
so where where a shortcut or job
um returns an image you can actually ask
questions that give back data so
um I want to get the face data back so
you use the same kind of
request
do
um so you use the same kind of request
but you actually say
face data equals true I hope I'm
remembering that right
and so then if I did that properly it
will just come back with
um
the the Json item okay
uh
all right I don't remember what it is
but basically
it has updated data support too so back
in magically we had
um
so we can get back to the color palette
uh I don't remember yeah analyzer so it
actually gives you back the top X colors
and you know the the you know top five
most most present colors in that image
and other things like that
so yeah I think that is about
all I wanted to cover other than that uh
so so
I've made
um you know again magic magically
for jux to support to support images
within our app and
we're using it was working well I built
this mustacheify thing people at work
thought it was funny I presented a
Meetup called hackintow which if you
haven't you haven't seen before I
encourage you to check out
um but basically people just give stand
up and give five minute talks um some
random thing they built that wasn't
um
you know that's open source they're not
work related so
that presentation went really well it
was just a condensed version of this and
um
later that week someone
in London I think no Ohio heard about
heard about it
and made a Chrome extension that takes
every image on your page and
mustachifies it so as you're browsing
um so this got a little bit of traction
and my servers were crashing constantly
then later uh GitHub released this was
before I was working there released
cubot and one of the handful built-in
commands was mustache find me so you
could say mustache find me uh you know
O.J Simpson and it would
fetch an image from Google images and
and apply it
has brought down my servers again and so
so yeah this is the sort of like weird
success story of this little app that
complete joke uh that's that's by far
the most successful thing I've ever made
um I yeah it's getting
let's see so in the past 24 hours it's
getting an average of 102 requests a
minute uh my
the that API I'm using I registered for
a free account
um and I'm over my limit by
a hundred no way one million 970 No 19
million yeah 19 million uh requests but
they haven't implemented uh capping yeah
that's that's the blue is how much I
ever made
um yeah so that's
that's magically and mustache five the
little the little apps that no one knew
you needed
thank you
uh really quick a couple Shameless plugs
uh Jesse Chan Norris asked me to tell
you that goruko uh the the Gotham Ruby
conference uh call for proposal is open
for another few weeks so you should
definitely do that they are open to
non-ruby topics also and you know not
necessarily experts you know you don't
have to be an expert uh also if you're a
newbie I run a Meetup called hacker
hours that
is like a community of people learning
to code and we need twice a week so uh
if you
want to learn more Ruby if you want to
get feedback on your code or whatever I
encourage you to check it out thanks for
listening
thank you